the bishop of manchester david walker is
one of those who signed a letter
condemning the government's rwandan
policy saying that britain has become
more hostile to those who are the
world's most vulnerable and let's talk
to him now right reverend david walker
joins me now thank you very much for
joining us sir why did you sign this
letter why do you believe these flights
shame us as a nation
well i think the first thing to say is
this is every single bishop who serves
in the house of lords agreed to sign
this letter within a few hours of the
text first being circulated so this is
that in itself is quite unusual and i
hope give something of a sense of the
depth of our concern about this it's
something we've been opposing for some
time
i in fact in my own name proposed
amendments in the house of lords only a
few weeks ago to try to have this
stopped we were defeated by a very small
majority only five votes uh when it was
actually put to the vote this is
something a lot of people feel is
entirely inappropriate for a country
like britain that has a
a proud heritage over the decades of
providing a safe refuge for people who
are genuine asylum seekers genuine
refugees
but but what about those
on the government side who will say you
know you you're talking this letter
about compassion about fairness and
about justice
that there are those who come to this
country and apply for asylum through the
legal channels
and and do it that way these people who
are coming in are not doing that they're
circumventing it which is not fair to
those who have have gone through the
legal system
nobody wants people to be uh arriving in
this country in in small boats risking
their lives on the open seas nobody
wants people to be at the risk of human
traffickers who exploit them terribly on
their way here but what we have seen
over recent years is continuing attempts
to shut down the legal and safe routes
for people to get to this country and
simply closing down more roots making
the environment more hostile is not the
answer the answer is for there to be
safe ways for people who are in most
cases those who are
coming to the country through these
informal methods when they actually put
their case uh to the test they have
proven to be genuine refugees to have a
real right to the protection that the
1951 convention affords them so what
we're asking for is proper safe routes
to come into the uk not a continual
ratcheting up of more and more hostility
but but what of the government's point
that that if these flights take off even
if there are a small number of people on
board them
it will send a message to both those who
who would seek to get on the boats and
the people smugglers making money from
that misery to discourage them from
doing it in this dangerous and illegal
way and would encourage people to do it
at a legal route
i mean even the i think the senior
permanent secretary is in the home
office said there's no evidence that
that will be the case and immediately
after the policy was announced i think
for a few days there was a
suggestion there were fewer people
crossing the channel then the weather
cleared up
and suddenly the numbers were back to
what they've been before there's
absolutely no evidence to date that this
is going to act as a major deterrent on
people and
putting people's uh
rights at risk in the way that this is
happening rejecting people who have a
legitimate uh claim to asylum to refugee
status we just don't think is there is a
right way to go about it
do you think we as a nation have become
perhaps a little bit less tolerant or
less
compassionate over the last few years i
don't know if it's something linked to
covert or the fact that we are all very
much isolated within very small groups
but do you think generally there is less
tolerance in community for for others in
inverted commerce
um no i wouldn't i wouldn't say that
entirely look at the way that people
have responded to the ukrainian crisis
there's been an overwhelming uh welcome
for people who've been making their way
here from there in far surpassing i
think the other government's own uh
expectations in that but i think i think
at times people fear they can be they
can be led into fearing that somehow
these are
these refugees are going to change our
society and we're actually talking about
pretty small numbers who who end up in
the small boats and the numbers who come
when britain is not the main destination
for refugees in europe there are far
more refugees in other parts of the of
the european area and so you know we
have to pay
play our part take take our share of
those who are really fleeing war and
terror and persecution in their
homelands and i think once it's
presented
in that way i think people will will
support as they support the ukrainians
you talk about people perhaps some
people being scared fear and and you
raised of course that the homes for
ukraine scheme that the government um
the government came up with
what do you think about that when you
look at that and you contrast the way
that those are being welcomed from
ukraine you mentioned fear
do you think racism plays a part that
that people are more welcoming of those
in this country who look more like them
i think we all have an innate tendency
to to to feel more naturally
a kinship with people who look a bit
like us and we and seem to come from a
similar background but actually what
enriches our society is it is very
diversity i'm fortunate enough to live
in extremely diverse city in manchester
where generations of people have come
here often as refugees bringing their
talents and their skills adding to the
economy and the value of the community
and and so i think once people get to
know as real human beings those who are
coming and fleeing war and famine and
terror in other places i think those
attitudes do change the fear is often
fear of the unknown and as long as we
can conquer that i think i think people
become much more welcoming
and this obviously the idea of these
flights is to try and discourage people
traffickers do you have any thoughts as
to how
people could be discouraged from making
these perilous journeys
yes it's very simple and the way you
discourage people from making these
perilous journeys is by having safe
routes and that might begin with an
initial claim being very rapidly
assessed to see whether it looks the
whole water
before somebody arrives at the uk and
then having the opportunity people have
always historically had in these shores
to to make their case that they're
proven to be
genuine refugees then to have the rights
to stay here and rebuild their lives
after the trauma they suffered in the
same way that refugees have been doing
for for many many decades that's the
answer it's safe roots is not no roots